I hold
such good way
like if you work with me I
okay folks um couple of reminders you're
U I was looking at the master list I
know you all told me you picked a
company already but there still seem to
be some missing company names so around
5:00 today I'm going to send an email
out just to those people who've not put
their names in if you don't want that
embarrassment I would go fill in the
name between three or just pick a
company between now and five o'clock
know get it out of the way second is
your first quiz is a week from today let
me be very specific first 30 minutes of
class 1:30 to 2 so don't be late on that
day um it's open book open Notes open
displays you can even open up your
computer if that's where you have your
slides you can't start an Excel partly
because you don't need it the numbers
are simple enough that you can do them
in your head you can do them in a
calculator you can have a calculator on
your phone a calculator I'm perfect okay
with that but it's a 30 minute quiz and
there will be class after the quiz right
so any questions about the logistics of
the quiz so somebody remind me again
what do you have to do if you're going
to miss the
quiz remind me let me know before the
quiz that you're missing the quest right
so even it's two minutes before and you
come up with a good good excuse at least
I'm not going to ask you for a doctor's
not so if I have Co that always works me
I can't force you to come in with Co no
so you can create Co if you feel that's
your good reason for missing the quiz
but my advice is take the quiz because
if you do badly it's a one throwaway
quiz and if you do all three it's it's
good to get prepared for the
quiz you probably if you didn't read my
email yesterday which I'm at this point
I'm assuming you're not reading my
emails at all there will I have extra
office hours this week before from 9:15
to 10:15 and 12:15 to 1:15 Monday and
Wednesday today's is already behind you
but I'll also have a two-hour office
hour on Sunday why so late because I
have to wait till you review stuff
before you can have office hours so if
you're working through past quizzes and
there's something that's completely
puzzling you know come for those office
hours so today we have a lot on our
play let's see where we were we're
talking about the cost of equity
risk-free rate B Equity risk premium by
now you know you should at least have a
sense of what each one does the risk
free rate reflects the currency of your
choice the equity risk PR reflects the
geographies you Opera in your bait
reflects the business mix that you
have that gets the cost of equity but
Equity is only one of two ways of
raising Capital so today's class we're
going to talk about the cost of debt
vastly misunderstood and ignored much of
analysis and then talk about the weights
you need to go from cost of equity and
cost of debt to the cost of capital so
let's talk a little bit about the cost
of debt
I'm going to set up a very simplistic
example you have a company and you're
trying to estimate the cost of debt for
the company you look at its books and
they tell you they have a billion
dollars in debt that they've already
taken and they tell you what at what
interest rate so you have a billion
dollars of debt on your books at a it's
called a book interest rate that's the
rate at which you borrowed it okay but
times have changed the risk free rate is
now
5% and given the risk in your company
the default risk you should be charging
a 2% default SP
so really the question is when you
compute the cost of debt for your
company should you go with the 4% that's
your actual cost of debt should you go
with the 7% which is this updated cost
of debt should you split the difference
and say I'll take the average of the
four and the
7% or maybe there's something else you
would do what do you think the right
answer is for the cost of debt you want
to try Leon
I'll tell you most people use the book
interest rate I've seen costy Capital
calculations using the book interest
rate and if you use the book interest
rate you are in this case at least being
completely irrational why because your
risk free rate is 5%
right other what would you use 7%
7% and you know how difficult this is as
a sales pitch to CFOs but I already have
data in my books it's only 4% why are
you charging me 7% because this is an
opportunity
cost when you think about investing in
this company today I can invest at 7% on
debt of equivalent risk why would I
accept a 4% rate a cost to Capital is
not the cost of funding your company
based on what you've already raised it's
a cost of funding your money today given
the opportunity
cost and why might book interest rates
be much lower than Market interest rates
let's go through some of the reasons
Michael rates went up rates went up
that's so if you borrowed the money in
2020 I can almost guarantee you many
companies have debt from 2020 that your
debt is going to look cheap in terms of
rates what else Joe what else could
cause in which which drives rates up so
IND um your credit score could have wors
you could have become a much riskier
company right maybe you were double a
rated then now you're double B rated and
there's a third reason which is in
normal shaped yield curve where
short-term rates are much lower than
long long-term rates if you take a lot
of short-term debt it can look like you
have lower rates than the market
interest R So today we're going to talk
about the logic of why we treat all debt
no matter what maturity as if it's
long-term debt and we attach an updated
cost of debt to it because that's the
only way you can be consistent when you
value
companies one more point and this is I
think uh I'm going to ask him a generic
question you look look at any Corporate
Finance evaluation textbooks textbook
the weights you're supposed to use for
your debt and Equity are market value
it's it's almost like religion right so
you're going through myop this was
it and sometimes it's good to step back
and ask why any of you working to a CFA
in you or have a CFA
already nobody
okay I don't have a CFA I have no desire
to be have a CF fa I don't want to have
a whiff of a CFA but for whatever reason
for the 30 last 30 plus years I've done
the keynote to the
cfas and I've kind of let the CF the
aimr which is the parent Organization
for the CFA know what I think about
what's happened to the CFA examination
process you know it would be if somebody
had been taking a CFA I could have asked
them about the torch it's about 7,500
pages of reading that you got to go
through there are three levels CFA 1 CFA
2 CFA 3 it's a it's an endurance test
you read 7,500 Pages there's an exam and
you ask what was on page
4335 and if you don't know you failed
the test why because the CFA to EV value
about 70% of people who take the exam
have to be failed so this is the way of
deciding who passes and fails and I said
you have to fail a lot of people but at
least fail them for the right reasons
not because they didn't know what was on
page 4
4,335 so I Begg them to allow me to
write the CFA exam I don't think they
ever ever going to do
it but let's suppose for a brief moment
they gave me this window of you can
write the CFA exam and give give out
certificates so here's the question why
in valuation and corporate finance do we
use market value weights for debt and
equity in Computing cost of
capital I want you to start thinking
about that question because I'm going to
give you the choices but start thinking
about that
question because if you can answer that
question I think you can come to kind of
a core understanding what a discounted
cash flow valuation don't give me the
answer yet but because I'll give you but
because I want you to think about it's
not an easy answer the easy answers are
going to lead you down Pathways you
don't want to go but if you want to use
market value weights you need market
value
equity and for a publicly traded company
that should be relatively simple right
share price times number of shares and
market value of debt which can be a bit
of a nightmare why because even
companies that issue bonds like Disney
has a portion of the debt that's Bank
debt that's not marked to
Market so what investment Banks do and
it comes to debt they wave their hands
say there's no market value and much of
practice you take market value of equity
of following the rules but you take Book
value of debt and use it as a proxy for
market value debt I can
understand but in this example let's
assume that billion dollars you saw was
a bank loan there was no market value
for it but what did I tell you about the
loan I told you the coupon rate on the
loan 4% I gave you the maturity in the
loan and I told you what the current
market interest rate was for that loan
7% can you give me a sense of if you had
to compute market value of the loan of
the debt would it be less than a billion
or more than a
billion tell me
why it's like a bond with a coupon rate
below the market interest rate right you
trade at below par
we'll talk about the mechanics of doing
it but the market value of that $1
billion loan would be less than a
billion so when I compute my cost of
capital my market value of equity will
be the billion but my market value of
debt will be less than a billion so the
debt ratio will actually be less than
50% even though on the face of it it
looks like it's a
50/50 so again mechanical issues that
can kind of entangle you in the cost of
capital so let's go back to the notes
where we left off on the cost of debt
and let's start building up to a cost of
debt and trust me it's a much less
intense process than bringing up the
cost of
equity so here's the basic rule when you
compute the cost of debt for a company
it's a rate at which you can borrow
money longterm today let me repeat that
again it's a rate in which you can
borrow money longterm today two key
words there today which means I don't
care what you have in your books I'm
actually making your life a lot simpler
because many companies might have 10 15
20 different different types of debt on
the balance sheet said don't even look
at it it's the rate of which you can
borrow money today and I don't care if
some of your debt is long-term
medium-term treat all of your debt as if
it's long-term
debt and the push back I get from CFOs
is but we have a lot of short-term debt
why are you saddling us with this much
higher cost of long-term debt why am I
doing this it seems like you know I'm
ignoring reality if a company has a lot
of short-term debt why am I not giving
it the credit for lower rates on the
short-term debt when I compute the cost
of capital paa you have any
ideas I noticed you're eating and I
wanted to put you on the spot that's
okay
sorry today's value is more of a optimal
opportunity but let me play Devil's
Advocate but I have my rate borrow money
low shortterm at 3% and the long-term
rate is 5% so I'm really paying only 3%
why are you giving me a 5%
rate in my cost of
capital we don't know how long you can
keep it at this actually we do right if
the short-term rate is 3% the long-term
rate is 5% what's a market telling you
about what short-term rates will look
like in the
future they'll go up right so if you
think about borrowing money for the next
10 years using shortterm borrowing you
borrow 3% for the next year you borrow
at the rate one year from now your
rolled over cost of short-term debt will
will be roughly your long-term debt so
I'm not contesting you go use all the
short-term debt you want but I'm not
going to give you a benefit of a lower
cost to Capital because you played the
term
structure right so it's going to be
longterm and it's going to be today
which means you don't care about what's
in the books you have to come up with
what that long-term cost of borrowing is
today and already you can see the pieces
you need you need a risk free rate which
risk free rate the same risk free rate
from which you built your cost of equity
if you see cost of capital starting with
two different risk rates you already
have an issue so I use a 10-year t-bond
rate as my starting point and to that I
need to add a default
spread a default spread capturing that
there's credit risk in companies they
borrow money if it's a riskier company
should charge a larger
spread once in a while you might think
you've hit pay dir if you have a company
that has bonds
outstanding the yield to maturity on
that Bond should already be that risk
free rate Plus to fall spread
right I almost never use a bond yield as
a cost of
debt there are two reasons anybody want
to guess what the two reasons why it
might be dangerous to use a bond yield
as a cost of
death can a risky company issue a safe
Bond yeah you can car ride to safest
asset so you can have a risky company
which issues a safe Bond so if I take
the bond yeld from that Bond and apply
to all of the debt of the company I'm
going to understate the cost of
debt and if you had special features to
the bond God help you right you got
convertible then then the interest rate
completely loses any but if you have
bonds outstanding there's a bonus you
get which you can still use to come up
with your cost of Deb it's not required
but what do most companies almost every
company that has bonds outstanding also
have availabity
all that 80% yeah but but there's
there's even more fundamental piece of
information I get on a company that is
born that I can use to estimate a AA
spread which is usually have a rating
are you requet to have a bond rating to
issue
bonds no you can actually issue bonds
without a rating but you're going to
have a problem people who were trying to
play bu Bond why don't you get yourself
rid I chose not
to and what do I read into that you must
have some really bad reasons why you
didn't go to a ratings agency therefore
I'm going so almost every company that
has a bond outstanding has ratings and
actually if you look at ratings ratings
agencies rate both companies and bonds
so if you have bonds that are safe you
might give that Bond a doublea rating
but they'll also rate the company and if
you the rating for the company you're in
a sense home free to the degree that you
trust the rating ages CU if I know what
your rating is that rate in goes with a
default
spread and that default spread can be
added to your risk RIT now do you see
why cost of debt is so much easier than
cost of
equity yesterday I was looking at the
bond ratings for every rated company
from S&P you can get from Capital IQ out
of 48,000 companies you know how many
have a
rating by
2,500 so that's 2,500 many of you would
have picked one of those companies
because they're more high-profile
companies I have a rating and I can look
up the default spread that goes with the
rating but there are
45,500 companies which have no
ratings so what do I do with those act
like a ratings agency sounds like me a
messy process but ratings agencies are
the most transparent organizations in
the world not because they want to be
but because of what they reveal as
public information which is they tell
you what the rating of every company the
rate is it's public information they
also tell you what ratio
they use you can almost see chat GPT
saying I can do this and you know what
chat GPT can rate compan is the most
mechanical of all
processes 30 years ago and I wanted to
be a rating agency I didn't have chat
GPT to help me what what I did was I
downloaded the rating for every rated
company I downloaded the eight ratios
that they claimed to use to get the
rating and I did some reverse
engineering you know what I mean by
reverse engineering I sorted the
companies based in ratings and I tried
to to guess which ratio is causing them
to give companies different ratings and
how much work is it
doing 30 years ago that assessment and
Still Remains true today if you have a
non-financial service company one ratio
carries the bulk of the weight in
explaining ratings it's the interest
coverage ratio the interest coverage
ratio is just operating income divided
by the interest expense so if you're a
lended do you want that number to be a
high number or a low number you want a
high number you want good protection so
the higher the interest coverage ratio
the safer you are as a
company and what I did as an add-on is I
created a lookup table based and rated
companies where if you tell me what your
interest coverage ratio is I'll go to
that lookup table andal assess what
rating you should have I call this a
synthetic rating to make it clear that
this isn't coming from Moody's or S&P
this is coming from my taking Moody's
and S&P ratings and reverse engineering
to come up with the rating for your
company yes predicted
number
you predicted number and what say they
actually use current interest coverage
ratios the only predictive part comes
about that they know your history that
your number there's no predictive power
in anything that ratings agencies do
other than using historical data
right so the company I'm going to use
this for is embro company I've been
visiting off and on for the last 50
pages I took their operating income and
there because the numbers were W little
year to year I took the average
operating income over time divide by
interest expense and I came up with an
interest coverage ratio of
3.56 I have to somehow convert that 3.56
into a rating right so here's the lookup
table and you'll see the most recent
version on my web web page because I
updated start of every year you're
saying why are there two sets of numbers
because the world isn't fair if you're a
large company you can get a higher
rating with a lower interest coverage
ratio than a small company two sets of
rules so the first set of numbers of a
large company so if your interest
coverage ratio is greater than 8.5 and
you're a large company where large is
Define purely in terms of market cap
greater than five billion then your
rating should be AAA but to be a small
company the AAA rating you need a much
higher interest coverage
ratio I'm going to keep it simple
because I'm not a fixed income guy if
I'm within shouting distance of the
actual rating I'm okay so if you look at
embr interest coverage ratio of 3.5 5 6
in terms of market cap it was a large
company already 3.56 translates into an
A minus rating and in 2004 the default
spread for an A minus rated company was
1% I'm pretty much done I've got a
default spread based on the synthetic
rating I can add to the rcre rate
there's one little tweak I have to worry
about which is EMB Brier is a Brazilian
company you say so what this is another
unfair component of the part of the
process for the longest time ratings
agencies when they rated companies had
what was called a rating ceiling which
was no company in a country was allowed
to have a rating higher than the
country you could be a really safe
Venezuelan company and guess what your
rating could never exceed Triple C
you're saying that's not fair hey life
isn't fair talk to a Greek company
trying to borrow money in 2013 you
walked into bank and I'm a Greek company
the bank said 30% plus so you haven't
looked at my financial you're a Greek
company so the final piece of the puzzle
is if you're in an emerging market and
you're doing the synthetic R if you're
using an actual rating you're going to
be okay because when S&P rates and Bri
they factor in the fact that it's a
Brazilian company so the actual rating
will already reflect country risk but if
you're using a synthetic ratings process
the country risk becomes a separate
issue so you get the cost of debt then I
start with the risk-free rate because I
was doing everything in US dollars bond
rate I had the default spread for the
company which was 1% but then I have to
bring in at least some of the Brazilian
default spread into the equation saying
you're a Brazilian company so when
people lend money to you they will
factor that in if you want to be safe
add the entire country default spread on
so you take the risk free rate plus
company default spread plus country
default spread embri gets so much of its
revenues from outside Brazil and US
dollars that at least in 2004 it was
actually safe for than the Brazilian
government when it borrowed money in
dollars so basically what you see is a
portion of the default R he's saying why
2/3 you can use the variation of the
Lambda approach if you want to get that
2/3 but as I said if you feel
uncomfortable estimating the 2/3 just
add the entire country default spread so
risk-free rate plus default spread gives
you cost of debt if it's an Emerging
Market company and you're doing a
synthetic rating you'll have two default
spreads to bring in and that gives me a
cost of debt for the company 9.29%
in US dollar
terms now that table you saw 3500 plus
companies mostly us companies used to be
almost entirely us companies 20 years
ago and let's face it the markets where
I need the synthetic rating the most are
markets like Indonesia and India and
Brazil and the question is can I take
the table built up using primarily us
and some European companies and apply to
merging markets
I can with a caveat if your risk free
rate is roughly similar to mine so if
you're doing an Indian company with the
Indian reped risk free rate is 5%
shouting distance of the US dollar rree
rate you know what I'm going to take the
default spreads from that table add it
on to the Indian risk free rate and say
that's a cost of debt for the
company but if you're doing a Turkish
company your risk free rate is 21% you
might be a AAA rated company but you're
not borrowing at 21.5% or 21.7 my guess
is the default spreads will have to get
bigger if your risk-free rates become
much higher we'll talk about what to do
when you have really high risk free rate
currencies because this is a mess that
you saw with the equity risk premium as
well all our default spreads and risk
premiums are dollar based numbers and
you can use them on other currencies if
the risk free rates are close but if
they become you know very different then
you got to ask what can I do to do
things differently and I'll give you a
way out but the cost of debt you have to
come up you can never use the book
interest rate now don't fall back on
that because it'll be a terrible
estimate of the actual cost of debt
yes
yeah but they're two separate numbers
weighted average right so you're not
double counting right you're multiplying
by the weights so if you have 60% if in
fact if I did not include in each one
then I'll be undercounted so it affects
both my cost of putting the cost of debt
ad's question was when we do cost of
equity we bring in country risk through
a country risk premium built on the
default spread when we do cost of debt
looks like we're doing the same thing
aren't we double counting but remember
the cost of capital reflects weights so
you're not double counting you're
actually bringing it through both
components now that default spread
number that you saw in 2004 does change
over time why does it change for the
same reasons Equity risk premiums change
over time which is this battle between
fear and greed right you get scared what
do you do you push up the price of risk
you get greedy and you feel good the
number goes down so this is actually
default spreads in 2022 the year that
was a tumultuous year for the equity
risk premium it went started the year at
about 4% went up to about 5.7% 5.9% by
the end of the year why because
inflation scared people if inflation is
caring people in the equity Market why
would you expect any different in the
bond market so in 2022 if you look at
default spreads over the course of the
year every single rating class you saw
default spreads go up AAA it went up by
only 0.14% but if you look at C or lower
it went up by almost 5.57% the lower the
rating the bigger the worry Factor the
default spreads wide which means if you
computed the cost of debt for your
company at the start of 2022 and then at
the end of 2022 you got a double whing
one is your risk free rate went from
1.51% to 3.88% much higher base and on
top of that you had a much higher
default
spread my worry at the end of 2022 is
the cost of debt had gone up so much
it's the biggest one-year change in the
cost of debt for us companies in history
is whether they would be able to survive
without defaulting and when I wrote the
piece on De debt yesterday where I
looked through 2023 and 24 so far
fingers crossed nothing bad has happened
yet yet but what's going to be the true
test of these higher interest rates and
whether companies can carry
them a recession a global economic
slowdown and we came off a decade of 2%
3% rates we're now looking at 5 6% rates
and you know you got to give the market
credit the companies have been resilient
enough so far but I think the true test
will be can they handle it through a
recession because they haven't paid down
Deb cuz that was the other question is
Will companies start to have less debt
now that rates have gone you know gone
up they haven't the amount of debt is
still up than like 10 trillion just in
the
US and just to show you how much defa
spreads VAR over time in this graph you
have the default spread at the start of
every year from 2021 to 2025 so when you
go to my website and you look up the
synthetic rating the default spreads you
will have are at the start of 2025 can
you use them in
May fingers cross if there's no crisis
you're going to be okay through me but
if something terrible happens this month
or next month all bets are off I'll give
you a way of updating this to fall
spread because you don't want to stay
with the stale spread if markets are
kind of imploding and there's a crisis
causing risk price of risk to go
up any questions about synthetic rating
risk free rates cost of
debt yes how
youate first where does the cost of debt
go it goes into a cost of capital which
is weighted by much so if they have no
debt then becomes an nonissue they're
revolving debt they have debt right the
debt is on average through the course of
the year so the revolving debt might be
you take it in March you pay it off in
November it doesn't show up in your
December balance sheet but during the
course of the year you did use debt so I
would still bring that debt in I'd
attach a long-term cost to debt to even
though it's revolving short-term debt
and I'd go through the same process of
default spread and the risk rate because
there'll be interest expenses if you use
debt if you never use
debt it's irrelevant I don't care what
your cost of debt is because your cost
of capital will be the cost of back but
if you do use that but it's seasonal
then I'll bring it in through that
average number for the
year now I want to take a little tangent
here the cost of debt here is a market
based number risk free rate default
spreads once in a while though companies
might have access to what I call sub
subsidized debt subsidized debt is
basically somebody lending money to a
company at below Market rates why would
they do
that why do government sometimes do
this
they because they want to encourage
people who might otherwise not have been
able to start businesses they have a
social purpose it might be an economic
purpose a part of the country that's
under in fact I think part of the the
tax reform acts last year year before is
if you built a factory in some part of
the the country where they felt that or
it could be a green Energy company want
to encourage so governments do it and of
course you had green bonds right with
impact investing the essence of a green
bond is you're actually buying a bond
and accepting a rate less than the
market set rate why because you want to
do good you want to make the world a
better place but for whatever reason
sometimes companies can have access to
debt that is subsidized have a very
pragmatic question let's assume that and
where we comput the market set number to
be 9.29% as a cost of debt that the
Brazilian government lends money to them
at 6% why because embri used to be a
government-owned company it's a crown
jewel for Brazilian industry an
aerospace company they're lending money
at a below market rate you're trying to
compute the cost of capital for the
company and you're trying to use decide
what cost of debt to use and here are
your choices you can use a subsidized
cost of debt saying I have access to
lower rate debt I'm going to ref that my
cost of capital you can reflect the fair
cost of Deb 9.25% saying this is a
subsidy I don't want to build it in but
in which case what are you doing you're
missing that entire benefit you're
getting from lower rate or maybe there
is a way you can split the difference
because with each one of these I think
with each of the first two there is a
problem with the 6% into your cost of
capital if you leave it permanently
you're assuming you get a subsidy
forever you might over value the company
with 9.29% if you leave it in
permanently you're missing the subsidy
value is there a way I can bring in the
subsidy value into my
valuation without bring the cash
flow let's be more specific what is that
cash flow benefit I'm getting because
I'm getting subsidized de can we
quantify
it um through the tax savings on the
interest
first let's get the interest payment if
I hadn't had the subsidized debt I'd
have paid 9.29% right so let's say I
have a billion dollars in debt I'd have
had 92,000 or 92.9 million in interest
expenses because the government is
giving me money at a subsid I'm paying
only 60 million I'm saving 32.9 million
for how long for as long as a subsidized
loan will last let's it for the next 10
years $32.9 million in savings you can
factor out the tax savings you'd have on
that but the present value of what
you're saving because you get the
cheaper debt will be a subsidy value for
your competition that way when you do
your regular cost of capital you can
leave the cost of debt at 9.29% Value
the company as if there's no subsidy and
bring in the subsidy separately saying
what's the advantage of doing this one
is you don't make the subsidy permanent
right second do governments ever give
you stuff without expecting something in
return in my experience that's never the
case so in return for the subsidy the
government is going to ask you to do
something which is going to cost you
somewhere so if you ask me does the
subsidy Mak sense I can bring in the
rest of the picture I'm saying in return
for this subsidy here's what you're
required to do as a company you might
have to sell your green energy at a
below market
rate and this is how much you're losing
and net you actually gain only this much
or might you might actually lose from
the government subsidy you bring it in
so when you have a subsidize subsidy of
any sort whether it's a cost of debt or
whether you have a higher price you're
allowed to charge as a company it's
probably best to keep it out of your
discounted cash flow valuation and bring
it in as a separate
piece because it'll keep you it'll allow
you to control when the subsidy ends and
how much value it adds so the bottom
line here is I would use the 9.29% cost
of Deb my cost of capital and then after
I'm done with my valuation I take that
interest tax savings I got because the
sub put a finite life on it saying the
government's going to give this to me
for the next 10 years take the present
value of those savings and add that on
to my value and that way the subsidy
value is part of the
process
yes discounted use subid that's a good
question so now that we're talking about
the subsidy what is the right discount
rate so leave me through what know how
risky are these cash
flows no it's a it's a cost of debt it's
a debt cash flow right and how do we
capture the it's a cost of debt so
basically you take that savings you
discount back at the cost of debt why
the cost of debt because it's a cash
flow to debt it's a predictable cash
flow and the present value will then be
so use that principle whenever you're
saying what discount rate should I use
look at the risk of the cash flow and
work backwards because it always lead
you to the right place yes you had a
question or no yeah I thought you had
your hand up so let's go back to the
weight question that I started at the
start of the class I said market value
weights
I'll go through some of the reasons I've
heard because when I throw this out I do
it that with cfas they already have the
CFA but I threaten to take it away from
them they give me the wrong answer you
know so I'll go through some of the
answers I want you to play it through
and say whether you're okay with this
answer do we use market value rates
because the
market is usually
right what's the danger of choosing that
as your
reason what do we do we take this comput
a cost of capital with the market values
then we use the cost of capital to
Discount the cash flows we come up with
an intrinsic value and then what do we
do we compare to the market price and
you say this stock is undervalued this
stock is overv valued you have me over a
barrel because you can say but you
started the process telling the market
is usually right how come you're now
telling me the market is wrong so that's
not it is it because Market values are
easy to
obtain relative to what book values you
look it up shareholders equity is just
as easy in fact you could argue that
book value of debt is easier to get than
market value debt so that can't be it is
because you take my my view and my
cynical view that accountants don't know
what they're doing and maybe book values
mean absolutely nothing and for some
companies I think that's true but for
most companies that might be a bit of an
overstatement so what the heck is
it cuz I see me I'll tell you the
internal inconsistency that if you're a
quantitative person that's going to
create some some pause here we use
market value weats right we come up with
the cost of
capital we value the business we
subtract our debt we come up with an
intrinsic value of equity which is
different from the market value of
equity that we used to come up with the
cost of cap you have two values of
equity Co inhabiting in the same
discounted cash flow valuation how do
you get away with that there's actually
an explanation for why we use Market
values of equity to compute cost of
capital and still can contend at the end
of the process the intrinsic value of
equity is higher or lower than the
market
value every discounted cashlo valuation
is actually an exercise in an
acquisition valuation where you're going
out and buying the entire company saying
but that's not what I'm planning to do I
don't know what you're planning to do
the DCF acts on that premise that you're
buying all of the equity in the company
out there and all of the debt in the
company out there in market value terms
now do you see why we use market value
it's a transac actional value to buy
this company you can't pay intrinsic
value you can
try you can't go around and say you know
I think the intrinsic value of Invidia
is only $45 I'd like to pay $45 no it's
not going to get you anywhere you got to
pay the market value we use Market
values of equity and debt not because
the market is right because that's what
we have to
pay so when you look at cost of capital
you're getting a transactional cost of
funding the business and of of course
you're saying what if my stock is not
trade what if I have a private business
there's no market value I would still
say you can't use Book value we'll talk
about know techniques we use to get
around the prom but we cannot use Book
value book value is meaningless in an
acquisition valuation as weights for
your cost of capital no private business
owner is going to sell you his or her
business at Book value right so you have
to come up with an estimate of market
value it's not as convenient because
it's not out there but it's always
market
value so let's bring these all together
for EMB as I said we've been leading up
to this page for 50 pages let's start
with the cost of equity first I made a
currency choice in 2004 to do the cost
of capital entirely in US Dollars why
because I was desperate there was no
risk free rate in r no Government Bond
rate so I'm going to do it in dollar so
my risk free rate is the TB
rate for the cost of equity I came up
with the the bottom of beta for EMB so
reflecting the fact that I don't trusted
regression beta I multiplied that bottom
of beta by a mature Market
premium and then remember because 's
risk comes primarily from one country
Brazil I use the Lambda approach of
course if you want to use a weighted
average Equity risk premium instead of
the Lambda approach you'll get you
pretty close to the same number my cost
of equity in dollar terms is 10.7% for
the cost of debt I start with the same
risk free rate but I had two default
spreads 1% is for the company based on
the synthetic rating 4% is for the
country because it's a Brazilian company
I come up with a
9.29% cost of equity cost of debt cost
of debt will almost always be lower than
the cost of
equity don't go to the next step and say
therefore I should use all debt because
that's not going to
follow but that's even before taxes
right why because the lenders are always
first in line you're behind the lenders
if they're charging 9. 29% you should be
charging a little bit more for the
weights market value Equity Was Easy
Share Price times number of shares
$3,781 million or in R terms 11.04
billion
R but when I tried to estimate the
market value of debt all I found was a
book value of debt 3,350 I'm sorry 1,953
mil and if I follow the investment
banking practice that would become my
market Val and to be quite honest won't
make that much of a difference I can get
away with it but I'm going to give you a
neat little trick you can use to convert
the book value of debt into market value
you saw this in my corporate finance
class but you going see it again one way
you can easily convert book Debt to
Market debt it's treated it like a
coupon Bond the 1,953 million will
become the face value of the debt the
interest expenses 222 million from the
income statement will become the coupon
every year and the debt at an average
maturity four years so think of a
four-year bond with 222 million in
coupon every year for the next four
years 1,953 million the end of the
fourth year and since we know the cost
of debt is
9.29% you discount those you're pricing
a bond and not surprisingly the price
you get for the bond is different from
the book value why because their book
interest rate and this is the reverse of
the problem that we started the class
with was actually higher than the market
interest rate so the market value of
debt ended up being higher than the book
value
de by 2 thou so it's 283 million that's
what I used for my cost of capital
calculation again if you use the
1953 as your debt value and come up with
the cost of capital wouldn't have been
the end of the world but the kinds of
companies you have to worry companies
like Michael mentioned where the rating
has dropped or the market value of debt
can be very different or interest rates
have gone up a lot like they did in 2022
this is a good practice to have in your
back pocket when somebody says there is
is no market value of debt therefore we
can't estimate it you can say stop we
can estimate it and here's a way of do
it the end game here is the if you look
at the weights the equity is about 84%
of capital debt is about 16% and the
cost of capital weighted average is
99.97% so this is where all of the
numbers essentially come together risk
free rate the beta the risk premium none
of individually none of them is comp
licated none of them is you know rocket
science but you have so many moving
pieces that if you're not careful it's
easy to be inconsistent in this
process remember we talked about Turkish
L the risk fre rate was 20% saying well
what do I do all my risk premiums and
default spreads in dollars one is you
can stay with the local currencies and
2004 the Brazilian REI risk free rate
was 12% I could have stayed with that as
a risk free rate built on top of it but
the cost of capital i' end up with will
reflect this inconsistency high risk
free rate and risk premiums in dollars
so if you have a currency like the
Turkish leer and you're doing valuation
in it here's the safest way to do it do
everything in US dollars for the cost of
capital everything in US Dollars even
though you want to do everything in L or
R you do it in dollars 99.97% was the
dollar cost to cap for embri right but
remember that needle trick we Ed to
convert risk free rates in one currency
to another it's based on inflation let's
say the inflation rate INRI is 8% the
inflation rate in dollars is 2% if
you're in a hurry you can add the 6% to
the 9.97 15.97% but if you want to do
this right with the high inflation you
bring those numbers in and my REI cost
of capital will be 16.44% why that extra
inflation is on top notice there's no
other adjustment country risk is already
embedded in my dollar cost of capital
all of the things you worry about are in
there so that inconsistency between
using local currency risk free rates and
dollar spreads is driving you crazy and
it does Drive some people crazy do
everything in US Dollars and at the last
stage to the inflation
correction one final point my cost of
capital calculation only two ways you
could raise Capital right debt and
Equity once in a while and I hope this
doesn't happen to you when you open up
your company you'll see debt and you'll
see equity and you'll see hybrids what
are hybrids they're part debt and part
Equity the most common hybrid is a
convertible Bond somebody explained to
me how a convertible Bond works with so
what do I get when I buy a convertible
Bond but if first let's start with the
St so do I get a coupon every
year yeah and there's a face value so it
looks like a regular Bond but I have an
added feature at any point in time I
have the choice so it's an option you
have to convert into shares but why why
might you want to do that what would
cause you to want to convert a bond into
shares if you have convertible bonds on
palent you're converting like crazy
because you want to hold a bond and get
a 3% coupon you can convert to shares
which are worth five times what they
originally were so convertible bond is a
straight Bond plus a conversion option
the convertible bond is debt the
conversion option is equity remember you
could have raised Equity by issuing
warrants which is you skip the bond part
entirely and raise Equity through
options European companies actually are
you know use warrants fairly
frequently all you've done is combine
Them In One Security so if you have a
convertible Bond my advice is break it
up and I'll show you a way of doing it
into the straight Bond portion put it
into
and the conversion option portion which
goes into Equity your problem goes
away there's another security that I
absolutely hate it's called preferred
stock and not the Latin American version
of preferred stock which is really
common stock without voting rights it's
a US version of preferred stock here's
how us the US version of preferred stock
works you buy preferred stock you get a
fixed dividend the dividend is set up
front it's not like common stock and if
the company companies unable to pay the
dividend most preferred stock the
dividend gets accumulated and you get
paid in future
years looks a lot like a bond
right and many people are attempted to
take the preferred stock and include
with debt but there's one catch what's a
catch why isn't preferred stock even
though it is a fixed dividend and looks
like a bond why might you not want to
include it in that no tax there is no
tax benefit so when you throw it in as
debt and you multiply by 1 minus t your
counting a tax benefit that doesn't
exist I have some really bad news we
have preferred stock you have no choice
but to open a third source of capital I
try avoiding doing this unless I'm
forced but if you're a company which say
20 25 30% of your Capital com from
preferred stock you're going to have
cost of equity times weight of equity
after tax cost of debt times weight of
debt Plus cost of preferred stock say
where do I get that very simply it's a
preferred dividend deal there's no
risk-free rate beta capm none of that
stuff is needed it's whatever the
preferred dividend is divided by the
preferred stock price if it's 8% that's
your cost of preferred stock multiplied
by the weight of preferred
stock preferred stock is actually a very
inefficient way of raising Capital right
because your company and you borrow
money I give you a tax benefit but if
you should preferred stock you often are
paying roughly the same cash outflow
right dividends or even more and you
don't get a tax benefit so why do you
think companies issue preferred stock
any
ideas
yes to make it look like they have less
debt so they're giving up the tax
advantage to make it look like they have
less debt and you know where this makes
a difference in regulated companies with
The Regulators have this very strange
idea that something is called Equity
it's an equity in its name it must be
Equity banks are the biggest issue as a
preferred stock
in the US because the regulatory Capital
ratios allow you to count preferred
stock as part of your regulatory Capital
so they're borrowing money they're
giving up a tax benefit but they're
looking safe on a tier one or a tier two
or a tier three capital ratio so often
when you see the use of preferred stock
you're seeing some regulatory flaw
playing out in how companies fund
themselves so before I leave this I want
to talk about how if I gave you a
convertible Bond you would separate it
into to straight debt and Equity let's
take a very simple example let's suppose
you have a company that has a
convertible bond with a face value of15
million and a coupon rate of 4% let me
pause right there if there were no
conversion option you're going to get 5
million coupons every year 4% of 125
million at the end of the 10th year
you're going to get 125 million let's
say the market interest rate for this
company based on its rating is
8% but asked you to price this Bond you
could right take the coupons the face
value discounted all back at 8% what you
get as a present value is 9.45 million
see what does that tell me if this were
a straight Bond you were buying it just
as a bond you'd pay 91
million but convertible debt is traded
let's say the market value of that
convertible debt is 140 million 91 of
that 140 million is for the debt what's
the other 49 million
for Equity so you don't have to Value
the options and you know basically if
you value one half the other half kind
of falls out so if I'm valuing this
company my cost of capital the 91
million is going to go in with the debt
the 49 million is going to go with the
equity my hybrid is now disappeared and
I'm back to having just debt and equity
in my capital structure again all you're
doing is drawing on bond pricing it's
amazing how Bond pricing can help you
out kind of clean up these conversion
options say how much are they
worth so that's it we have the cost of
Capital cost of equity coming from the
risk free rate the bait and the equity
risk premium the cost of debt reflecting
the rate at which you can borrow money
at the tax benefit you get on the cost
of debt is always at the margin so we're
already going to start a discussion of
tax rates because interest saves you
taxes on your last dollars of income you
apply the marginal tax rate to it and
the weights should be market value
weights and if you do have preferred
stock adding as the third component is
make sure the weights add up to
100% yes
yeah back to the preferred shares would
you view them differently trying to comp
a cost of capital if the preferred
shares were accumulative or we're not
that's a good question I think that it
does create more of a cash flow button
but it'll show up in the price so we
need the preferred dividend yeld if
they're cumulative the preferred
dividend yield will be lower than if
they're non-cumulative so to show up
already in the cost of preferred stock
so I would just let it go through
so that's a discount rate took us a
while to get there let's talk about cash
flows I'm going to lay out the big
picture and don't be intimidated by
looking at all the terms because I'm
going to just give you the big picture
of what we're trying to do remember
there are two ways we can estimate free
cash flow one is to equity one is to
firm if it's to equity it has to be
after debt payments so you start with
net income you subtract out what you're
reinvesting back in the business and I'm
going to divide what you're reinvesting
into three components one is what you
reinvesting into long-term assets Capa
but depreciation kind of offsets some of
that and what you reinvesting into
short-term assets which is working
capital inventory receivables you start
with net income you subtract out
reinvestment and then you also subtract
out other debt payments coming due and
if you're raising your debt that's cash
inflow so when you're doing free cash
load Equity start with net income you
subtract reinvestment you add add cash
from new debt you subtract cash for debt
you have to pay out and what you're left
with is free cash equ lots of
definitions we have to do is what goes
into capex depreciation we'll come back
to those but in in Big Picture terms
you're trying to estimate cash flows
after Deb
payments if you're looking at free cash
The Firm you can't start with net income
anymore
why because it's a pre- debt cash flow
net income is after interest expensive
you clim the income statement to operate
income and then you act like you pay
taxes on that Opera income let me
emphasize it again you don't pay taxes
on operating income but you have to act
like you pay taxes on operate income
that's why this is often called an
unlevered cash flow you're acting like
you have no
debt you net that taxes out and then you
subtract out the same reinvestment You
Did In The Free Cash Ro equity and
you're done free cash for the firm free
cash for the firm is a pre-b cash flow
free cash equity
is a post step cash flow so when you
look at the steps you need to get to
both cash flows first you need to get a
sensor so if I asked you what is the
free cash flow to last year you can't
even answer the question until I tell
you to to the firm or to equity but if I
say what was the free cash FL Equity
last year you start with the earnings
for the company you subtract out the
reinvestment that they put in and there
are lots of Tangles there of how what
you put into what if they do
Acquisitions what if they pay with stock
with acquisitions questions we will have
to confront and then you subtract out
debt cash flows if you're looking at
free cash flows de so we're going to go
through them and and take each part
separately you know in terms of earnings
and then what goes into capex and
depreciation working capital but that's
the sequence I'm going to send you a
link on a piece I did um a couple of
years ago where I took Microsoft and
just computed freeastro I in free Castro
a firm I did it precisely because I got
sick and tired of analysts talking about
free cash flow and just stopping
there the free cash flow of the firm is
and they would make up whatever free
cash flow definition they wanted Abid do
free cash flow in what sense is Abida
free there's a lot of stuff that you
have to do with the Abida so one of the
things we need is a little more
Precision when we talk about free cash
flow no now as you work through the past
quizzes on the free cash flow problems I
know some of you haven't looked at the
quizzes don't worry you still have a
week to go when you have time now still
not looked at the quizzes on Sunday
we'll have a problem you know you'll
notice there are multiple variants in
how I get to free cash of the firm or
free cash free cash The Firm there's a
long way you start with after tax Opera
income and do what I just did subtract
out the CH the the difference between
capex and depreciation and the change
working capital gives me free cash to
the firm I could consolidate everything
inside the brackets and call it
reinvestment in fact from the rest of
this class when we when you hear me talk
about reinvestment it is that
Consolidated number I often get people
pushing back when I do the reinvestment
why aren't you counting in depreciation
it's in there already because my measure
of reinvestment is capex minus
depreciation plus change in working
capital gets me to the same end but just
a different term
consolidating the third way I can
present the same thing is I take take
that dollar reinvestment stated as a
percentage of after tax oper
income I end up with the same free cash
flow but I can give it to you as a rate
the advantage of telling you the
percentage reinvested is it allows you
to compare different companies you
compare Microsoft to a small software
company if I told you the dollar
reinvestment how do you decide whether
you know which one's reinvesting more by
scaling it to after tax Opera income say
Microsoft invests 40% back as
reinvestment but Adobe invest 80% back
it allows you to make comparisons so I
don't want you to get confused because
you see multi equations the end game is
always free cash for the firm how I get
there can vary depending on what I'm
using as my intermediate stop to come up
with reinvestment and you can do the
same thing with free cash Ro Equity the
full definition is to take net income
subtract out reinvestment plus net debt
but again if I consolidate that I can
call it equity reinvestment which is
reinvestment minus debt or I can come up
with the rate that Equity reinvestment
as a percentage net income again for the
moment I know I'm throwing a lot of
terms at you but as we go further into
the class you're going to see me take
these numbers and present them in
Consolidated forms but I want you to
understand that I'm still doing exactly
what we've set up to do here come up
with pre- debt or post- debt cash
flows so that's my Microsoft calculation
in fact I do this to kind of get a sense
of what a company is doing I start with
the earnings number that's a green
number and then for free cash Lo Equity
I steep down by first looking at the
reinvestment and then that cash flows so
the gray is my free cash Equity lower
than my net income but it shows you
where the money went so it's a good way
of tracking the number because on a
spreadsheet it's kind of the numbers
it's kind of difficult to see but in
this I don't know we even know what this
chart is called an Excel waterfall chart
or something basically you start with
the number and you scale down you can
see the number scale down as you
reinvest as you set money
aside okay so we're going to start on
the cash flow process with accounting
earnings you already know where I come
from when it comes to accounting
earnings but it is the starting point
you need the earnings without the
earnings we kind of stuck so there are
three things I want to talk about in the
context of earnings the first is I'm
ring the company today not at the start
of the year not two years ago so I want
the most updated number I can for
earnings now so if you remember we
talked about how to get the more updated
number you can't use the last 10K
sometimes if it's from
2023 so that's a pretty simple fix
second for your company last year
strange things might have happened
earning strangely good things or
strangely bad things I don't want to be
mysterious but if you're an oil company
and oil prices went to $120 last year I
can almost guarantee you that the
earnings are going to look
amazing 2020 oil prices went to 32 there
wasn't a single Oil Company in the world
that reported profits for the year
because at $32 other than aramco who
else can make money
right so your have earnings going up and
down we have to figure out a way how to
normalize those numbers just a fancy way
of saying if I just used last year's
numbers God only knows where to live so
we're going to update we're going to
normalize and then we're going to clean
up clean up after whom the accounts
they've left a little bit of a mess
because they're not always consistent
about how they classify expenses I'm
going to talk about the three buckets
accountants claim to use for expenses
operating capital and financing and how
they put the wrong items into these
buckets and it creates a mess for me
when I'm valuing companies so let's
start with the updated part and this is
the easiest part and it's getting easier
and easier to do everywhere in fact if
you use sources like yagu Finance or
Capital IQ they have a trail month
number always at the
end but how do they get there very
simply by adding up the last four
quarters but if you remember there is a
shortcut you can use to get the L
training 12 month numbers all you need
is 110k and your most recent 10q let's
say you know Leon that your most recent
10q is from September first three
quarters of 2024 you have the 2023 10K
do you see how you can combine those two
to create a trailing 12 month
number we go to the last 10q it's going
to report what you did in the quarter
but it's also going to report your
revenues earnings all the numbers for
the first three quarters of 2024 right
and it'll show a comparison to the first
three quarters of 20 23 it'll be right
next so here's what you're going to do
you're going to take the 2024 2023 10K
numbers you're going to add the first
three quarters of 2024 and subtract out
the first three quar so it's basically
three columns fact it's a very simple
exercise take the 10K take the 10 Cube
create three columns the last column
subtract out the 2023 first three
quarters add the first three quarters
2024 you got the trailing 12 month
numbers why because you want the most
updated numbers you can get some of you
will start with that by end of March
hopefully your 2024 10K would have come
out if you have a calendar year end and
then you can replace with full 10K
numbers and for a brief moment of Glory
you don't have to do any adjustments you
can just live off the 10K and then the
first quarter numbers will come out and
the pain starts AR fresh right so don't
think of it as something extra it's just
you know it's something that has to be
done when you value the company there
are some parts of the world where you
don't get full quarterly reports Stu
Europe for a long time you'd get pieces
every quarter revenues Opera income but
not but increasingly around the world
both IFRS and GAP are pushing towards
full quarterly reports and it gets
easier than to create trailing 12 month
numbers but even
with markets like the US where you have
disclosure on a quarterly basis there'll
be some items where you have to go back
to the last 10 G I'll give you the ex
the one of the things we're going to
talk about is stock based compensation
and in the 10K you're told how many
options are outstanding management
options when they come due and what the
average exercise price is you need that
to complete your value per share but
they don't report that in the 10 cues so
if you're valuing a palente you might
have the most updated trailing 12 month
numbers for everything else but on this
one you're kind of stuck with the last
10K what do you do beggar can't be
chooses you take what you can get move
on and your defense will be this is the
most updated number I could get but this
particular input so that's a first stop
updating because you want to Value the
company as of
today now comes that messy part okay I
still remember my first accounting
classman professor came in with three
cardboard boxes very low Tech you know
setup and he labeled
them the first box he labeled operating
expenses second he label Capital
expenses and 30 label financing expenses
and he said in accounting were religious
about about the way we classify expenses
he was lying but I didn't know then that
he was lying because he said if you have
an expense that creates a benefit only
in the current year it goes into the
operating expense box if you have an
expense that creates benefits over many
years it goes into the capital expense
box and if expense associated with the
use of debt it goes into the financing
expense
box so things like labor material
operating expenses things like land
equipment machinery capital expens
and interest
expens and if they stay true to that
then our life would be very simple in
valuation but there are at least two
items that are routinely miscategorized
one no longer but for a long ter is
miscategorized a financing expense that
was treated routinely as an operating
expense and I'm talking about
leases we'll talk about what makes for a
financing expens and you can very
quickly see why Leisa should never have
been treated this operating expend
so the first fix is if there are
expenses like leases then we've got to
move them into the financing expense
column what that does is moves an item
that was above the operating income to
below the operating still an expense
your net income might not be affected
your operating the second item is a
capital expense that we know is a
capital expense that is routinely be
treated as an operating expense and we
talked about this in the start of the
class quiz last time things like r R&D
we'll talk about the accounting
rationale for why they do what they do
it doesn't make any sense but we'll talk
about in any
way because it screws up all of our
numbers it makes our income mated our
Capital invest basically everything we
need in valuation is mated so we're
going to try to fix that we're not going
to wait for accountants to fix it we're
going to fix it now because otherwise
we'll be waiting a long time so let's
start with leases are leases an issue
depends on the sector here right retail
a restaurant you're going to have a lot
of lease expenses that's the way you
borrow money but if you're a company
like steel or auto and truck there might
not be much in leases that you have to
worry about so looking across companies
the amount of issue leases is going to
vary across sectors but among those
sectors where leases are a big
issue what accountants used to do with
leases before 2019 was almost
criminal they took your biggest debt off
the books they made operating expense
which made you almost you know blind to
the fact that this company was in the
verge of bankruptcy you had no idea how
much debt it had so let's start with why
leases are a financing expense when you
look at an expense what is the key
question you have to answer to decide
whether something is a financing expense
or an operating
expense what is it about interest that
makes it a financing
expense it's a contract ual obligation
right the minute I introduce the word
contractual obligation I don't care what
you call it it is effectively debt are
leases a contractual obligation I think
so it you can argue maybe there's more
flexibility in a lease I'm not
disagreeing with any of that having
flexible debt is still Deb leases have
always been debt accountants have always
known it's been debt but because they
got trapped in by a legacy Choice made
100 years ago it took them a long time
to get around to that same conclusion so
when you look at leases clearly leases
are dead so starting about 30 years ago
I decided that when I computed debt
ratios for companies I could not stay
with the accounting definition of debt
because they were missing a big chunk of
what should make for debt so I'm going
to take you through the process of
capitalizing leases I know accountants
do it for you right now but I want you
to see what's behind the numbers so when
you see lease dead at Walmart how the
heck do those accountants come up with
the number so here's the first
step if you decide leases are
effectively dead you got to convert
those lease commitments you've already
entered into into that remember when you
sign that contract you have commitments
to make and for the longest time even
before accountants came to their sense
and treating leas is right those
commitments have been in a footnote but
you could see this is my commitment for
next year two years out three years out
four years out 5 years out and beyond
your five you gave me a Luma all I'm
going to do is take those commitments
discount them back to today at the
pre-tax cost of debt why because these
are commitments that I'm treating like
debt payments the right discount rate
has to be the cost of debt what I get as
present value will be the debt value of
leases so I'm going to put in the
balance sheet as debt and I have a
problem what's a problem my balance
sheet no longer balances right so what
do I do I have to create a counter asset
so when you look at Walmart's balance
sheet now you'll see a lead lease debt
and you see a lease
asset and once I create a lease asset
the nightmares continue what do I have
to do in subsequent periods I got to
depreciate it this is like Give a Mouse
a Cookie Time right basically invite
give them cookie wants milk you give the
milk he has to take a bath you take a
bath next thing he's taking over your
house right when you decide to
capitalize leases you got to go the
distance so you got to restate the debt
you got to restate the assets you got to
restate the operating income everything
is going to be different when you
capitalize leases your income statement
changes your balance sheet changes now
you see why account counts were so
reluctant to make this change that's 80
years of CPA down the drain because you
now have to think about a new way of
showing this on your income statement
balance sheet so let's let's take an
example this was in Pre 20109 which is
when accounting came to sens in 2003 I
was looking at the Gap and this was in
the Gap was actually a thriving retail
store which is opening new stores those
is are done and gone gone and are in the
past but in 2003 in their footnotes this
is what the lease the Gap told me that
they had lease commitments of 899
million one year from now 846 so
basically those are my commitments for
the next five years and in the sixth
year they gave me a Lumpa of
1,976 million which has spread out over
2 years so I have the commitments for
the these are not expected lease
payments these are actual commitments
you've entered into you discount those
commitments back at the pre-tax cost of
debt of about 6% what you get as a
present value is about $4.4 billion he's
saying what does that
mean their least commitments at the Gap
if you bring them together is
effectively the equivalent of borrowing
4.4 billion if you look at the looked at
the gaps balance sheet in 2003 their
their conventional debt was 1.97 billion
so if by trusted accountants that have
stopped there but if you add in the 4.4
billion the Gap actually owed about 6.4
billion the Gap is a lot more lever than
you thought it was when you capitalize
leases and that's always going to be the
case when you capitalize leases your
debt value will go up because you
broaden this contractual commitment onto
the book and of course once I do this I
can no longer use the operating income
that they report which was 1,2 million
because that operating income was after
Le expenses being treated as an
operating expense so I do the right
thing I add back the lease expense
saying I shouldn't have subtracted it
out but there's one loose enter TI I now
have a lease asset that's going to
depreciate over time I used to seven
your life and then do fancy things I
straight line depreciation my adjusted
operating income is 1,362 million so the
Gap has a lot more de than I thought it
did it's a it's a much more profitable
company so this is not just about
working companies I'm going to give it
some good things and I'm going to give
it some bad things and I'm going to ask
you the question what's the net effect
going to be on Val the Gap is more
profitable than I thought it was it's a
lot more dep than I thought it did in
fact if you're in a hurry and you
wouldn't do a shortcut you can take the
stated operating income add back what I
call the imputed interest expense
because this had truly been debt at a 6%
rate but do it only if you're in a hurry
when you have the full the full the full
calculation is to add back the entire
lease expense and subtract out the
depreciation I actually did this at the
Gap in 2003 because they were hearing
talk that accountants would be
capitalizing leases they didn't
understand that accountant when they did
the talk would take 16 years to do it so
they were very interested what will this
mean for us as a company I have to tell
you as I went through each step they
went through stages of delirium before
crashing in one so start with the good
news I said now that that's what
accountants are doing this is what the
numbers will look like if I Street
leases as debt so I gave them a good
news first I said you're a much more
profitable
company when I capitalize leases my
operating income goes from 1.012 billion
to 1362 billion they were happy then I
said little bit of bad news right now in
your balance sheet you show only 1.97
billion in debt you would look like you
have more debt and they were a little
disappointed and then I said that's good
news because when I comput your cost of
capital with the old definition of debt
your cost of capital was
7.31 and now it's going to be 6.25% at
this stage are Heights of delirium
higher earnings lower cost of capital
life is good and then I hit them at the
final piece and I said there one final
catcher the way we compute what you're
making on your Investments the return on
Capital return equi is based in book
values right now that book value of debt
gives me a return on capital of 12.9%
but if I capitalize leases and I bring
it on to the Bucks I have much more
invested Capital your return Capital
will be only 99.3%
at this stage they had no idea whether
they were coming or going they said okay
we have higher earnings a lower cost of
capital but a return on capital is also
a dropped so what does this mean for our
value as a company and I gave them a
suggestion on a shortcut they could use
to see what effect the value would
go see the spread between the return on
Capital and the cost of capital it's a
very generic measure of how much more or
how much you earn as an excess return
before I capitalized leases that number
was
5.59% they after I capitalized
leases both numbers Chang but the spread
has gone to about 3.05% what does it
tell me the Gap is in a good business
but not as good as I thought it was I
did this for about 20 retail companies
in 2004 for seven of them the spread
actually went from positive to negative
once you capitalize leases that's when
you cross that you've essentially taken
a company that you thought was in a good
business and you realize it's a bad
business it changes the entire story for
the company because every time they grow
now they're making you less
valuable so let's be very clear we
capitalize leases not because we're
nitpicking but because we want to get a
sense of am I in a good business and
there is zero chance you can answer that
question at a retail restaurant if you
don't capitalize
Lees so let's review so basically if you
let the accountants do it they will
mistake the operating inome the way they
did so 2019 you subtract out the leas
expense your operating income is
misstated your book capital is misstated
your debt ratios are misstated basically
everything you do coming so the reason
we're doing it is to get a much clearer
sense of what is my company making his
earnings how much does it all what is
its true cost of capital and what is it
earning over and above that cost of
capital now why are leases dedicate
they're contractual commitments right
how many of you Netflix subscribers
I'm
one they lot of their content now is
made within the company but they still
have content that they rent out for the
longest time the Avengers movies were in
Netflix Disney plus has reclaimed it
they had a 5-year contract Seinfeld was
in Netflix suits was on Netflix as well
these are shows made by somebody else so
how does Netflix get to show these shows
on their service what do they do Michael
they have a fiveyear contract a 10e
contract with with disne is a fiveyear
contract that's why it took them three
years to get it back because there was
time left on the
contract they agree to pay 80 million a
year for the next 5 years is that a
contractual commitment yeah in fact if
you look at the Netflix footnotes they
have lease commitments and right next to
it you see content commitments when I
value Netflix those content commitments
become the equivalent of debt because
they are contractual commitments I bring
them in if you
that Saudi soccer team that signed
Ronaldo what does he get 125 million a
year for the next four years or
something they tried to send Mai for a
billion dollars over the next8 years I
don't think they succeeded but are those
contractual
commitments the Mets have a lot more
debt today than they did a few months
ago
why they've got this sort of bond
outstanding right 745 765 million over
the next 10 years contractual commitment
again I'm not saying it's good or bad
but when you look at sports franchises
the bulk of your debt might take the
home with these long-term player
contracts and we have to treat them
exactly the way we treat
leases I'm going to at least uh you know
close off this process finally in 2019
accounting came to its
census in much of the word IFRS and GAP
now require that all these commitments
be treated as death
and of course accountants being
accountant they can't just write a
simple rule they've got to write 100
rules with exceptions and shades so you
know all these things you can do to
escape it being treated as that but at
least they've come around to the right
sense of it's a contractual commitment
so today for most of you you're lucky it
should be already in but I'll tell you
something I still don't trust
accountants to get that lease debt right
one of the nice things is they still
show me the footnotes with the
contractual commitment so I can check so
start end of every year for the last 5
years I've taken the accounting numbers
from Capital IQ for lease dat I've
computed the present value of lease
commitments which are also on Capital IQ
and I've compared the two numbers so if
you take Australia New Zealand and
Canada the a accounting estimate Lee
debt is 8.4 billion my estimate is 13.6
billion in fact across the board my
estimates of debt are higher than the
accounting estimates of debt and there's
a very simple reason remember I said
accountants have these sub rules and
Escape hatches basically if you have
flexible leases and you can get out of
them accountants give you an escape
hatch the only problem is you say that
makes sense is companies read those
rules and guess what they then do on
their lease
contracts they retroactively go in and
so in parts of the world what's
happening is companies have gained the
system to keep leases off the box but
before you dump on accountants you know
what analysts are doing they're
reversing what accountants are doing to
go back to pre 20109 numbers
even if accountants did the right thing
analysts don't seem to like it they say
I'd like to go back to a pre 20109 world
because I don't get this new
stuff so it's easy to blame the
accountant but there's a whole lot of
blame to go
around yes Michael 2019 was there like
um like a boom and downgrades from the
rating agencies no see the rating
agencies already we doing it in fact you
know how rating treated leases they
multipli the lease commitment by eight
and they treated as dead why eight
because in 1969 that was roughly the
present value of a 12E lease and they've
been too lazy to fix it but ratings
agencies have always when they looked at
Walmart and this is the thing
accountants are the last people to come
around to recognition that this is dead
everybody else in the game is kind of
caught it
already I'm going to at least start the
R&D process now I wanted to think about
it because I'm going to start the next
class with it R&D is obviously
capex accountants still treat his
operating expense so the start of next
class I'm going to start with the
question why do accountants treat
R&D as an operating expense because
that's going to give us an opening as to
how to fix this because it is a problem
it's going to mean we can't value
technology companies or pharmaceutical
companies using the accounting
statements because they flawed by the
treatment of R&D so I will see you on
Wednesday and we will talk about R&D